[Music]
um he's saying oh women are only going
for successful guys but women have
literally been taught from a young age
to go for a guy that's stable that has a
good job not just by their mothers by
their fathers too because no dad would
accept that guy who doesn't have his
[ __ ] together or let's say so well I
think I think that women
um are told from a young age they don't
need a man and you can You Can Be Your
Own Boss and Chase the bag
as well yeah yeah so I don't really
think yeah yeah I don't really find that
like
um
at least under a certain age I don't see
women chasing the guys with like
that are like driven and hardworking and
like good men I see them chasing more of
like the bad boys
yeah I think a lot of women or these
days now we're going for a lot of like
image yeah guys that drive nice cars
guys that have money and have and maybe
because it's social media and this whole
thing of looking a certain way
um if you drive this you have this I
feel like women are now going for that
that's probably why they do end up with
men that are just [ __ ] because these men
don't actually have personality it's
just all the front basically and they'll
rather put up with that if it means
they're sitting in a nice car and
they're going to the nicest restaurants
like you said novel Cove they'll rubber
put up with that then I guess that's the
bearment that they'll rather have that
bare minimum if it means that they look
good doing it
but then also like Pearl said like
um men are intimidated by successful
women so I didn't say they're
intimidated no they are not a bit more I
don't think so I don't think I'd care
like I think they do a lot of men have
this ego thing I think they're only
intimidated by women that should throw
their money in their face
so like I don't I don't think
um like I don't think most men are
intimidated by women that have a lot of
money it's more the women that think
they're better than everyone else and
it's not really that they're intimidated
they just don't like them or want to
deal with them because they think
they're better than everyone else two
two hundred thousand dollar engagement
ring
but yeah but then the men carrying
themselves like that as well when they
have money it's the same well I think
they just carry themselves like they're
the prize because they are listen I
think it definitely is ego they can feel
a bit intimidated you know if their
their wife is earning a lot of money and
then she wants a certain thing and he
can't provide it for her that that could
like hit his ego and make him but I I
think I think that's the point though
like so a girl will like the girl will
don't doesn't mind ego right if
someone's quite uh they're like
confident stuff like that shall we but
then when a female is very ego driven
right that's off-putting to a lot of men
because that isn't you know like you
said you're like oh well why shouldn't I
like they've got money they've made
their own money and it's just like we
don't really care like like type things
so it's not a very motherly thing to be
yeah and it's not really don't care
because don't get me wrong like if I had
the same girl and one one earn more and
one earn less of course I'm gonna go for
the one who earned more but that's not
the that's not a deciding like if you
had a chart of like a game chart with
all these like stats that's not the
deciding factor it's really low on the
scale
well I think it's because a lot of times
women like we think like women and so we
think that men want the things we want
but they just don't care it's like it's
it's like um have you ever had a guy
have like a really cool shoe collection
do you care
okay she cares
I'm sorry too
um one one other thing that came up was
was that you know it dawned upon me that
you know there are there are couples
where the uh where the the man's
successful and the woman isn't and there
are couples where both of them are
successful they're very very very few
uh couples where the woman successful
and the husband isn't
you know there's a you know there's this
kind of Trope of the of the the power
couple
but um
you know it just very very seldom
happens and the relationship needs to be
incredibly strong to sustain that as
well would you guys
um find a guy attractive if he made less
money than you significantly
would that matter to you I'm not really
to be honest I don't think that equates
to attraction yeah because like yeah you
might earn less but do you know how do
you know how to carry yourself I feel
like that's most important there's so
many other boxes to tip would that
question change if they were older so
say if they're 35 and they earn less
than you
would your answer change mine would
last question yeah yeah
I know like
for us as women sometimes we look at
like older men as like okay they're a
lot older than us or they are older than
us they've accomplished a lot more
because they've been on the planet
um for a longer period of time but then
if they haven't got a job or not earning
as much then it's like okay what have
you been doing all of this time at your
big age it just it doesn't really I
don't know it's hard it's hard though
because you don't know people's you know
stories or backgrounds or yeah I mean I
mean that just shows though that like
you are looking for money in a way it
might not be like that thing but because
they've reached a certain age where you
think they're not going to earn any more
money than this so it does mean you do
matter about it I feel personally for me
it's more an opinion of like what my
parents and what their expectations of
me are especially like obviously being a
woman living in a patriarchal society
like a lot of things are not really
geared towards women's safety or women
being able to earn as much money as men
or
um being able to reach high CEO
positions and start talking about yeah
what are you talking about our whole
society is geared towards women women
make 70 to 80 of consumer buying
decisions our whole media is geared
towards women empowerment there's no
men's empowerment okay well I I don't
know this is this stick so I'm
definitely wrong here but I'm just
saying in terms of like
um you know
um maybe more so Traditional Values then
and the way that like women
um see men as um a way a type of
security or like a safety net so to
speak so when I'm looking at it from
kind of that perspective if we're really
looking at a man that is the example 35
who's earning a lot less than a female
that is a lot younger than for me
personally would be questionable because
then bringing that home to my family and
my family's like okay so you're a young
woman how is your potential husband
going to be able to look after you and
not only you but your children do you
think it's fair to ask men to provide
traditional outcomes when we're not
traditional women
depends on the couple like the the
couple has to be compatible together and
it depends on whether they um consider
or value societal values in their
relationship no so I'm just saying like
by and large like I know there's going
to be new you know what I mean I know
there's going to be Nuance but I'm
saying like by and large do you think
it's fair to to ask for traditional
outcomes when we're not traditional
women anymore
so I would say if you're not a virgin
like you're not a traditional woman
because a traditional woman like
traditionally women were virgins when
they got married and a traditional
outcome is when the man is still
expected to protect and provide so it's
like we're asking for traditional
outcomes when we're not traditional
ourselves yeah because even in your
situation you were a bit traditional
yourself there because when you answer
that you you worry about what your
family's gonna think then why couldn't
you be the provider like if you truly
felt that way why couldn't you that it
doesn't matter if the man's a nurse and
earning like 20K or whatever why
couldn't you be the big you know the
main thing so even in yourself your
answers a bit uh traditional yeah I
guess so I feel like that's maybe
because I value like my parents opinion
but then also I wouldn't want to be a
provider like I feel as though sometimes
um women they take on this big struggle
of yeah I have to do everything
um or they don't necessarily have the
support of like men
um in order to like reach their goals
and aspirations and then look talking
after everyone else but themselves so
it's just like oh I personally I
wouldn't prefer to like be like the main
earner in my household like I want to
put my feet up I want to relax like the
struggle life is not for me
so you should I don't know yeah the
traditional ways like men want the same
as we do like you want to be cleaned
cooked for being taken care of so would
you say modern women by and large offer
that because they also want Purity in
Youth and we don't offer either of those
things Purity I don't think is really a
major thing to be honest because we're
women really pure back then we don't
know 100 yeah yeah we can't guarantee
that I have a question for the man would
you want a girl that slept with 100
people no would you want a girl that
slept with 100 no but my answer is
probably different to what you expect
like because my reason is just like I
don't actually care that it's 100 people
it's just the fact that I wouldn't go
for that type of girl who is willing to
sleep with 100 people so it's not the
number that puts me off it's just then I
know that's that type of person like
yeah so like it's like if I was looking
at a guy and he cheated on every single
girl he'd been with like I could infer
that he's a cheater so if a girl's been
sleeping around for the past decade he
can infer she's a hoe not exactly like
your your body can't does not amount to
who you are well yeah people do change
as well yeah but it amounts to your
decision-making abilities
but then that deter that those decision
abilities may be determined because of
like childhood trauma or like things
that that person has gone through or
experienced or experienced like a true
negative that's true experience but the
world doesn't owe you understanding
so the guy the guy like when you come to
a guy he doesn't owe you understanding
and if you come to him and he can tell
you something around like I think it's
in his right to not want to date you
then I have a question do you think that
a male like for us being women do you
think uh men owe us respect
um I mean I think everyone deserves like
a basic level of like I don't even want
to say respects I guess respect is
earned but like human decency but I
think like you should be selective in
who you date and I think men have a
right to be selected and who they date
and if they don't want to date a girl
that slept around I think that's
perfectly fine and I wouldn't want my
brother to date a girl that's like bang
the whole football team as
I was just banned on Tick Tock and
demonetized on
on Isis on this platform if you want to
help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible